[Musique]
avec jean françois ouellette et carla
beauvais bonsoir à vous deux carla
d'abord 1600 emplois quand même c'est un
autre coup dur pour bien des
travailleurs est ce qu'il fallait
s'attendre à ça compte tenu que
l'entreprise a quand même beaucoup
changé dans les dernières années les
derniers mois et même les dernières
semaines bien évidemment je pense que là
le contexte pandémique que nous impose
de prendre certaines décisions passent à
travers de cette crise là on avait déjà
eu des mises à pied au courant de l'été
et donc je pense que c'est la continuité
de ce kit de ce convoi d'un secteur de
l'aviation d'aéronautique et c'est à
prévoir aussi là le secteur est très à
mal présentement et la dette a été
coupée l'enjeu de la dette il est là
depuis longtemps pour bombardier coupé
de moitié avec la vente de bombardier
transport jean françois est ce qu est ce
qu on assure aujourd'hui vous pensez
malgré les mauvaises nouvelles de
suppressions d'emplois la pérennité de
l'entreprise
ouais mais je pense l'entreprise a fait
des choix qui était difficile en
effectivement à éradiquer une portion de
la dette important don c'est aussi des
parties d'actifs importants cela dit
mais ce qui est important de regarder
dans un cas comme celui-là c'était ce
qu'on appelle le cash flow est censément
les flux financiers les voies réservées
qui sont générés par les activités puis
la capacité de l'entreprise à honorer
ses dettes énormes ans de l'assistant de
d'actifs qui était probablement pas
aussi générateur de cash flow de vue
financier on se remet dans une position
beaucoup plus favorable
je pense que c'est effectivement comme
gardel disent elles aussi la continuité
de décisions qui ont été prises très
difficile certaines presque imposée par
ce que l'entreprise a pris comme
décision
mais je pense qu'on est bien en selle
pour le futur effectivement avec cette
décision
ok l'association internationale des
machinistes et des travailleurs de
l'aérospatiale le syndicat a dénoncé
aujourd'hui l'absence d' aide du
gouvernement fédéral dans ces temps de
pandémie à l'aviation à l'aéronautique
vous en pensez-quoi carreleur de cela
mais on en parle depuis le début de la
crise effectivement
on l'a vu dans d'autres pays comme
l'allemagne qui a vraiment fait une aide
massive à ce secteur là pour le moment
le gouvernement de justin trudeau n'a
pas offert d' aide au secteur de
l'aviation et mais on parle d'une aide
mais c'est pas n'importe quel prix aussi
je pense que c'est dans les pourparlers
avec le gouvernement c'est comment va
aider le secteur est ce que le
gouvernement même comme en allemagne de
pouvoir avoir un capital et un capital
participative dans ces entreprises là
parce que c'est une chose de de dédé et
de relever des six entreprises privées
l'homme mais aussi il faut penser aux
contribuables absolument et on se pose
la question pour le gouvernement fédéral
puis on a posé aujourd'hui la question
aussi à françois legault est ce que si
bombardier a besoin d'un soutien
financier
est-ce qu'on va de l'avant et à quelles
conditions en condition jean-françois
c'est la partie qui peut rapidement
devenir dogmatique laisse qu'on investit
dans des entreprises privées
plusieurs directs l'obésité en bourse
donc si le gouvernement quel qu'il soit
provincial et fédéral veut injecter des
fonds dans une reprise qu'à acheter des
actions sauf que partout dans le monde
ailleurs particulièrement d'europe en
oeuvre des aides directes mais aussi
indirects sont prend des prises de
participation par exemple sous la forme
de des banques turques ont conversé l'on
fait un prêt qui doit être converti en
ex si on sujet mais les choses tournent
à peu prés mâles
ici on voit très mal la prise de
participation des gouvernements dans le
capital actions des entreprises parce
que on se ramasse à maître flamand des
fonctionnaires ou des politiciens dans
un conseil d'administration pourront pas
toujours
disons les intérêts aussi bien placé que
le restant des actionnaires très de
valeur mais qui allait parler de
l'allemagne
notre façon d des entreprises simard ya
beaucoup plus indirecte l'allemagne
offre par exemple le programme
d'assurance emploi qui est beaucoup plus
flexible que le nôtre qui permet par
exemple est une entreprise qui peut se
délester de 50% de ses employés au lieu
de mettre la moitié de ses employés
apportent me permet d'avoir un horaire
de travail qui répartit sur deux jours
et demi sur cinq par exemple et des deux
jours et demi sur cinq que vous ne
travaillez plus mais là vous êtes
compensée par l'assurance-emploi et ça
c'est des aigles sont beaucoup plus
intéressantes parce que ça permet de
garder son talent à l'intérieur de
l'organisation puisque c'est vraiment la
guerre en ce moment pour la part des
entreprises
je mentionne que les actions sont à 61
cents pour bombardier en baisse de 12
cents aujourd'hui c'est un recul de 16
et demi pour cent de l'action pour
bombardier
aujourd'hui je vous emmène sur un autre
sujet si vous le voulez bien on a
diffusé un reportage hier sur les
pourboires dans les restaurants et dans
les bars c'est vraiment un tout autre
dossier des restaurateurs il ya des
propriétaires de bars qui décide
d'abandonner le pourboire qu'on juge
discriminatoire voici d'abord un extrait
de reportage qu'on a présenté hier de
notre collègue philippe de montigny à
yahoo a travaillé dans l'industrie de la
restauration à toronto pendant une
quinzaine d'années en tant que personnes
noires descendante d'esclave la question
du pourvoir est lourde de sens qu'est-ce
nos clients décident de notre valeur
alors eu un des arguments évoqués c'est
que la pratique est très enracinée dans
l'esclave âge et qu'elle perpétue des
inégalités car là qu'est ce que vous en
pensez le sort ce que j'en pense qu'on
est en plus dans le cadre de mon
histoire des noirs vous savez ces mois
de février et c'est ce qui est bien avec
l'histoire c'est qu'on en apprend tous
les jours moi je n'étais même pas au
courant de cette c'est historique de
l'histoire du pourboire donc j'ai appris
des choses en regardant ce reportage là
bien évidemment au delà de la question
de la race je pense que c'est
inéquitable en fait ce système n'a été
ni équitable et il faudrait le revoir au
grand complet si ce n'est pas de
l'enrayer parce que ça crée aussi cette
dualité de qui mérite à pourboire qui ne
mérite pas un pouvoir alors que je pense
qu'on devrait aller sur s'assurer que
tous et chacun puisse avoir un salaire
décent à la base très intéressant vous
en pensez quoi jean françois est ce que
c'est une pratique discriminatoire et
est-ce qu'on doit abandonner le
pourboire
ouais mais je vais je prouve parler de
racisme longtemps j'ai publié là dessus
je me saint céré intéresser beaucoup de
sueur avec la question plus tôt c'est
mal
les pacistes bien qu'ils soient
inconscients puis on s'en sert pour dire
ben semble donc en fait on a une
personne qui est par exemple de rasseoir
ou qui est issu d'une minorité ethnique
ou par exemple troubles handicap
quelconque par exemple pour y être jugés
comme moins compétents moins compétente
et faire en sorte d'être de bord son
travail jugées comme inférieure est ce
encore une fois de manière très
inconsciente ce qui amène pour boire
moins élevé de la part des consommateurs
et ça c'est bien documenté donc c'est
pas quelque chose de nouveau non pas du
tout et puis en fait la réalité c'est
que pour être faire un bon français
les pouvoirs devraient effectivement
exclu lancry carrément suicidaire
l'homme apparaît partout dans le monde
le sont en amérique du nord
issel ici qui n'inclut on peut le savoir
est ce qu'on devrait pas augmenter les
salaires ou mettre un pourboire
obligatoire le port est obligatoire en
fait des études un prix hommage du côté
des
des salaires en fait parce que je pense
que c'est en même temps moi je vais pas
chez le médecin puis je me demande est
ce qu'il va faire un bon travail fait
que je vais lui donner un pourboire je
pense que la qualité le service ça doit
faire partie de camper pour un service
d'avoir un bon service
si on veut donner au bord on prend le
données de façon individuelle mais je
pense qu'avant tout c'est assurer que
les gens ont un salaire décent et un
salaire vraiment à la hauteur du travail
qu'ils font maintenant les pouvoirs le
problème de l'imposer sur la facture
c'est qu'il ya beaucoup de restaurateurs
en fait qui disent que ça va augmenter
le coût de l'heure de leurs deux lors de
leurs plats ou de leur boisson
ils veulent pas nécessairement qu'avoir
un frein du public pour consommer parce
qu'ils vont voir que les prix sont
beaucoup plus élevés sur l'effet sur les
menus en fait donc s moi je pense qu'on
devrait y aller avec lie avec les
salaires à la ba oui oui c'est non je
suis d'accord en or mais en rouge tels
que moi j'étais tellement d'accord le
prix devrait refléter tombant ainsi que
les taxes d'ailleurs cette politique de
partitions pricing comme on l'appelle
dans le jargon recherche et c'est
quelque chose qui tend à disparaître
parce que les gens veulent savoir le
plein plus de ski mon pays vous savez
que si vous achetez vous en coûte 13 au
final pourquoi ne pas déjà mentionné que
le prix trésor public le sud pour boire
en plus parce que vous avez un service
exceptionnel mais vous le ferez mais
dans tous les cas le serveur laisse au
risque nous a servi aurait quelque chose
de c'est un débat très intéressant
le texte de philippe et sur notre site
web si ça vous intéresse pour ne passer
de reportages également et nous en avons
parlé ensemble ce soir merci à vous deux
merci à vous pour voir nos émissions en
entier rendez vous sur la chaîne ici et
redit